this year's Supporting Actor category
includes an idealistic rookie a devoted
husband a ruthless conman a crafty
wizard and a man who was a little bit of
all those things Howard Cosell they were
brought to life by these exceptional
actors this year's nominees for Best
Performance by an actor in a supporting
role Jim Broadbent in iris
Ethan Hawke in training day
Ben Kingsley in sexy beasts
ian mckellen in the Lord of the Rings
the Fellowship of the Ring
jon voight in a league
and the Oscar goes to Jim Broadbent in
Ireland
this is the first Academy Award
nomination for Jim Broadbent he also
played the kinetic theatre impresario
harold zidler in long
stone the crows and I'd like to thank
the Academy for this wonderful honor and
making iris was the most joyful
wonderful experience and for that much
thanks to intermedia to BBC Films and to
Miramax for getting behind it and
putting it out and above all to Richard
Eyre for writing a wonderful script with
Charles wood for directing with skill
intelligence humour and great talent and
for putting together a wonderful cast
for us to work with with Hugh Bonneville
as the younger me and Kate Winslet and
the special Judi Dench ooh I had a lot
to do with and I'd like to thank John
Bailey for who allowed us to plunder and
I'm sure misrepresent his life with Iris
and above all I'd like to thank my wife
Anastasia for coming with me on this
long and rather unpredictable journey
and good luck Moulin Rouge
you